yeah Williamsburg is like I don't even
know what it is I don't think
Williamsburg knows how to make anything
no they have they probably got a bunch
of organic [__] and and again let's
get back to the independent coffee shops
I had coffee one time
not gangster I had coffee one time like
one time
wait hold on
you've never had coffee in your life
gangster
it doesn't taste the time I had coffee
had to force myself to drink it you had
coffee once in your life yeah to stay up
and it's it kept me out guys
yeah I never been to Starbucks oh yeah
I've been to Starbucks and I picked out
a Bagel Boy cream cheese
that shit's crazy to me all right guys
this is the first time you've ever tried
coffee correct black coffee this is
straight coffee from 7-Eleven we're not
[__] 7-Eleven cut the check with that
being said cheers and you should take a
good drink though all right
hmm
okay
that's what I'm saying I had to see how
hot it is
dirty
try a little bit more
you gotta swallow a pause yo let it just
sit in your mouth for a little bit pause
hey yo
yo I'm crying
you know what that tastes like guys a
mortgage bills stress
a lot of [__] kids in the house I
just need to get through my [__] day
so drink some shitty coffee it's just
terrible
this is actually terrible
so would you recommend it no so you're
not gonna finish it right that's gonna
chose you oh I ain't put no milk I told
you it was gonna be ungentrified coffee
[__] no
there it is
good job guys that was hilarious
that was bad